I'm gonna be the head of my household
again and so I'm not going to be
circumvented in that
and so
if everybody's willing to conform
the patriarchy again I guess
yeah Cody Brown's demanding his wives
can form to patriarchy following
Christine's exit from their plural
marriage yeah I didn't know I'd signed
up for patriarchy you've seen me say on
this show nobody is a prisoner here if
if this isn't working for you
you know it all goes down on Sister
Wives Janelle Robin and Mary are hit
with the news Christine's leaving Cody
After nearly 27 years of marriage
was so weird it's like are you guys sure
like you're sure sure yeah yeah I feel
like I like me better now as and I just
feel like I've been able to
really like raise my kids how I want to
and I really have more of an
independence and in the aftermath of
Christine's Newfound Independence Cody's
trying to make some changes within the
family I'm gonna be the head of my
household again and so I'm not going to
be circumvented in that
and so
if everybody's willing to conform
patriarchy again I guess
because
I've been fighting to make everybody
happy
my bitterness is out of trying to do
that
and not having the family that I had
thought about and designed and Janelle
she's not here for it yeah I didn't know
I'd signed up for patriarchy but that's
not what we all agreed on in the very
beginning but
ironically Janelle did sign up for
patriarchy when her and I made an
agreement that she would come into the
family she agreed wholeheartedly that
she would run her will into mine because
I had to be the head of the family and
she made that agreement with me Cody's
priority getting things back to how he
wants them to be and if it is too
awkward or if I don't feel like I'm the
head of my household when
um people around then I'm not going to
have the whole family together
I'm at a point now in my life where I
don't have time to waste on people who
won't respect me
or treat me with respect but Christine
leaving wasn't the only bombshell
dropped in the conversation do you
believe
and call marriage anymore I believe it
works for people who wanted to work for
them I believe if people have a
testimony of it they should live it do
you
no
yep Christine is done with Cody and
polygamy I prayed a lot when I was
deciding what to do with Cody and
wondering why I needed to live plural
marriage when I just prayed more and
looked at my life more and had more
conversations with God about the fact
that I was just freaking miserable I
really like living separate I like my
own space I like my own autonomy and as
the Brown family moves forward with this
new change it leaves the other wives
with some concerns this is just gonna
rock us it's a very very hard hard way
if we're not careful
if we're not very very very careful
I sure hope everybody's taking it
seriously
[Music]